[Musica]
sono un trentasettenne sono nato in bici
e ci andrò avanti ancora per 20 30 anni
ok dunque romperò le scatole a tutti voi
per secoli dei secoli
amen allora vittorio brumotti è stato
creato come personaggio televisivo circa
dieci anni fa arrivando a striscia la
notizia
ho iniziato a 11 anni con tredicesima o
una quattordicesima dei miei genitori ho
visto arriva la prima bicicletta
la prima bici amore a prima vista
tagliato il cordone ombelicale andavo in
giro per il paese
di lì cambia la mia vita arrivo in
televisione e passaggio successivo ma
nel mezzo riesco portare a casa un
titolo mondiale di bike trial questa
disciplina non conosciuta in italia
soffocata da sport maggiori in quanto
sporminore non considerato ma non mi
perdo non mi perdo e insisto con questa
bici ad attirare l'attenzione
l'attenzione in giro per le piazze in
giro per i miei cornicioni per i miei
palazzi e ad oggi per il mondo
il programma che mi ha visto appunto
emergere ma dato la popolarità ma la
bici ma ha dato un senso logico a tutto
quello che faccio
ed è stata la mia guida per sa lontano
da tutto quello che poteva essere fatale
per un quattordicenne il diciottenne un
trentenne e forse anche di più quando
c'era il periodo buio che tutti quanti
uscivano nelle nel weekend il
sottoscritto era sempre con una tuta da
bici e le mani callose ad allenarsi a
rientrare prima la sera per potersi
riallenare al mattino
dunque non finirò mai di ringraziare
questo mezzo a pedali
che oggigiorno sta diventando molto di
moda sta diventando un mezzo
comunicativo un mezzo per essere cool un
mezzo per essere a impatto zero però non
inquinare
succede che nel mezzo per cercare di
dare un senso logico questa disciplina
dovevo creare e per creare inizio
stabilire guinness record chine su
record è il mio guinness più che ho più
nel cuore è stato quello che ho che mi
ha visto a dubai dove ho risalito la
torre più alta al mondo che si chiama
burj khalifa una torre di 826 metri e ho
cercato con tutto l'impegno considera le
forze di scalare 4.000 scale 162 piani
in 2 ore e 20 senza mai appoggiare il
piede
naturalmente se non si complicava la
situazione della serie o spaccato la
bici al centesimo 110 109 piano 109
spacco la bici per fortuna da buon
ligure ho detto beling portiamo
trascorre se non finisco ci rimette i
soldi mi sono portato la bicicletta di
scorte e faccio il cambio bici e riesco
arrivare in cima e da guinness record ed
è stato un mio grande traguardo perché
al di fuori di quello che può essere la
parte televisiva
l'ho creato
con i miei sforzi con l'impegno dei miei
collaboratori aprire una nuova porta in
giro per il mondo ne arrivavo sconfitto
da una mia impresa che avevo cercato di
creare di scalare il monte everest con
la bici due anni di preparazione
una tecnica che mi portava a scalare
queste montagne senza marco ciari piedi
avevo alzato il mio ematocrito avevo
preparato qualsiasi cosa
un sacco di soldini spesi per queste
imprese ma purtroppo per motivi politici
mi hanno bloccato questa è una montagna
sacra
non poteva essere scenario di una
impresa dichiarata un pò circense il
circo ci fa ridere il circo fa lavorare
però in punta di piedi me ne sono andato
e allora detto facciamo un nuovo record
la burj khalifa e me la sono tatuata qua
grazie a quella e mi si sono aperte le
porte a dubai
tant'è che sono un cittadino di questa
bellissima nuova città che ospiterà nel
20 20 il nuovo expo collaboro con il
governo e sono sono schiume un po il
futuro inventarsi creare dal deserto il
nulla
creare il tutto ok non hanno arte non
hanno tutta la nostra storia ma hanno
risorse economiche e tanta voglia di
creare viterbo notti dunque ha trovato
un giusto compromesso stare a dubai riva
arrivare in italia e rompere le scatole
rompere le scatole tanti di voi magari
ha seguito le ultime mie avventure
avventura è un po dangerous però per
quanto mi riguarda non sono tanto
dangerous perché vittorio brumotti è se
schiaccia sul tasto e parte vi faccio
capire come è abituato a vivere
l'adrenalina come abituato ogni giorno
con la sua quotidianità affrontare cioè
io prendo la mia bici e vado a gasare a
sentirmi vivo con questo se parte ok
grand canyon
[Musica]
tracce sono senza bici dunque faccio
così se volete però è proprio di mia
spontanea volontà che non l'ho portata
perché ho deciso che un po come
valentino rossi no valentino rossi un
grande grandissimo forse il migliore di
tutti i tempi
e magari non si porta dietro sempre la
moto è un periodo che voglio comunicare
è un periodo che voglio far capire che
vitor brumotti non è solo bici ma voglio
essere un comunicatore e cercare di
essere uno stimolatore di adrenalina
perché io parlo con tanti giovani e li
trovo veramente scarichi litro veramente
focalizzati soltanto a fare viral fare
laiche a fare cose che non non è la vera
vita nello sport per e selettivo lo
sport se tu sei forte t'impegni fai una
dieta e ti concentri forse arrivi un
obiettivo non è like non è virtuale
dunque il primo prossimi 3 sempre lo
sport soprattutto che noi in italia
abbiamo i bambini più obesi d'europa
gli specialisti dicono che dovremmo
mettere i nostri piccoli a fare attività
almeno un'ora al giorno almeno e noi
grandi almeno mezz'ora ma nessuno trova
mai il tempo ci sono difficoltà abbiamo
mille scuse noi italiani e soprattutto
invece la fascia di mezzo che sono i
ragazzi 14 20 anni sono veramente
imprigionati in una trappola che è
quella di non voler accettare quello che
sono dunque prendono esempi sbagliati
io vedendo la televisione le fiction ho
notato che in italia vogliono scegliere
sempre la strada più facile non ascolto
nei saggi le persone più grande in
quanto attuato e in una fascia di mezzo
mi sento di poter dare dei messaggi
molto importanti e questi ragazzi
giovani ma anche coetanei allora mi sono
imbattuto in situazioni che mi hanno
portato a essere magari un po
chiacchierato in questo periodo non
voglio aprire troppo la parentesi
situazioni abbastanza gravi ma
affrontati con una semplicità sono qua
non è successo niente e hanno pubblicato
con faccia spaccata distrutto sono qua
sono intero
mi sto allenando tutti i giorni non è
successo niente si andrà avanti in una
maniera sempre simpatica col sorriso
solo quello che dico è è ora di finire
di avere di darla vinta alla l'omertà
cioè si può sconfiggere soprattutto con
l'utilizzo dei social attraverso i
social si può comunicare e si può
denunciare e ho notato che ultimamente
la polizia di stato utilizzato un app
che si chiama liu paul praticamente tu
puoi segnalare in diversi posti d'italia
con una foto e una breve segnalazione in
forma anonima
quel che sta accadendo questa è una cosa
fighissima e stanno partendo i primi
arresti le prime segnalazioni si parla
tra forze dell'ordine e cittadino in
forma anonima sono golosi tutto questo
con difficoltà leggo libri
lo capite grumo e molto terra terra ma
l'unica cosa che mi piace leggere tanto
su quello che accade nella nostra italia
che ha un cancro fortissimo che si
chiama mafia che si chiama ndrangheta
che si chiama camorra sacra corona unita
anonima sequestri mafia foggiana ce
l'abbiamo tutti noi però siamo il paese
più bello del mondo
i terremoti si batte per tutto ciò in
una maniera sempre soft e fa parte anche
del fai fondo ambiente italiano questo
questa entità queste queste persone che
cercano di tutelare il patrimonio
artistico di quello che ci fa splendere
nel mondo si dice soprattutto liscio
sotto merde pictures e dice no dialetto
perché noi ci facciamo vedere belli
bellissimi abbiamo tanti problemi
abbiamo un patrimonio artistico abbiamo
dei monumenti pazzeschi che vorrei
scalare sempre con la bici ma negli vado
a distruggere e allora mi batto anche
per questo per far capire che noi
abbiamo abbiamo il meglio e attraverso
la mia bici attraverso i miei social
sto avendo le mie piccole soddisfazioni
il tubo catodico la televisione sono al
primo posto ti fanno notare però ad
esempio questo video che ho fatto hand
made fatto con i miei operatori perché
una società di produzione tutto quello
che vedete in onda passata la mia testa
montaggio idee ha fatto più di 100
milioni di visualizzazioni
nel mese di agosto è stato uno dei video
più visti nel mondo per me un ragazzino
che viene da ragazzino che viene dalla
provincia di savona e fare un video uno
dei più visti al mondo che abbiamo
girato noi ragazzi liguri è stata una
situazione maggiore di quella di essere
in televisione la televisione ti fa
sentire pieno diego ti fa sentire ti fa
sollevare da terra e allora proprio per
quello ho lavorato sul mio personaggio
per mantenere sempre i piedi per terra
ogni volta che si andava in onda
pensavo che la televisione fosse
momentanea e allora cerco di lavorare in
sordina a 360 gradi di essere un
personaggio poliedrico e trovare sempre
il piano a b c d e tant'è che se non c'è
più la tv ci sono i social c'è lo sport
ci sono le amicizie
dunque bisogna sempre livellare il
giorno brumotti e questo e spero che
tanti di voi abbiano idee creative
possono dare del lavoro a tante altre
persone come faccio io il mio gruppo è
composto di circa appunto 20 ragazzi che
lavorano per me con me
la tavola rotonda si prendono decisioni
dal più piccolo che a vent'anni set che
sono io e si sfornano idee dunque questo
è quanto seguitemi e ci vediamo in giro
per le piazze ci vediamo su qualche
grattacielo e e poi la parola che mi
porta sempre fortuna a bombazza grazie
[Applauso]